well my name is mark Nesbit I work for
the analytics team and today I'll be
doing a very brief demo the new 5070
on-prem only analytics offload feature
as you see I'm currently logged into the
cloud management console for the on-prem
system if you navigate to settings
analytics this is a new tab we've
introduced in 5070 looking closely we
support for event types API events
monitoring events which is gateway and
management nude performance related data
log events are typically sent from the
Gateway and include error conditions and
other log events audit events are
typically show up in the notifications
bar up top here in CMC UI and API Mui
and include things as notifications when
an organization is created or an API is
published that you for each API for each
event type the user can either configure
the default analytics output which is
the default out of the box or they can
optionally select a second export option
to a third party system the fourth
output types we include or elasticsearch
kafka syslog and HTTP for the demo I'm
just going to show you how we can export
API events to through the HP output to
Splunk and also additionally show how we
can export monitor events through syslog
to smoke as well taking a look at the
syslog configuration first you can see
that the configuration is pretty
straightforward you just hit configure
come in select a host port protocol
optionally include some SSL related
information and hit update the user can
also send a testament to verify that
their connection information is correct
I've already configured this and it's
already running so if I come into Splunk
here and look for the data summary and
go into the sources you can see here's
my syslog listener and you can see
here's the actual performance monitoring
events received by Splunk coming back
for the API events I've already
configured an HTTP output for API
the configurations a little bit more
complex we must specify an h2 RL I've
shown an example with SSL configure
using the default TLS profile I've also
had to add a couple HTTP headers connect
to Splunk one is an authorization header
to authorize with the Splunk server and
the second one is the request channel
which helps slow determine where to send
the actual Analytics data this is also
configured so if I come in here and
invoke my API a few times we should now
be able to go back into Splunk go back
into the search here's the configure
DHCP output token click here and you
should be able to see the actual two or
three events i've just published and
that includes concludes my demo for
today thank you